no it's gotta be true we don't we don't
have slavery now at the very very least
like probably about the same talk doing
slavery so
I know that this is gonna disappoint me
I would have problems with somebody who
embraced all the doctrines associated
with Islam
Islamophobia started during the
terrorist attacks I think it has to be
now right
yeah individual Muslims may show
splendid qualities but the influence of
the religion paralyzes the social
development of those who follow it no
now I'll still say now for this one this
sounds like it comes from the mouth and
someone who is just sheer ignorant now I
am NOT nor ever have been in favor of
bringing about in any way the social and
political equality at the white and
black races is it been done right that's
interesting it's kind of weird to hear
this and hear where it's coming from I
mean you got the first mainstream
African American who is articulate and
bright and clean and a nice looking guy
I mean that's a story book man now then
Joe Wow by every immigrant who comes
here should be required within five
years to learn English or leave the
country definitely now I definitely
think that's now
definitely sounds like something people
would say now they're sending people
that have lots of problems and they're
bringing those problems with us they're
bringing drugs they're bringing crime
they're rapists and some I assume are
good people is it right now
this is Donald Trump right this was is
really hard I felt like all of these
quotes could have been said that I feel
like that girl from Mean Girls all the
time I just wish everyone could be happy
and get along history repeats itself and
it just this kind of like just shows
that